so yes we are finally back and now it's
time to lose a few more loved ones as in
today's video we are diving back into
Jujutsu kaizen's culling game your
thoughts hindi's colony was absolutely
insane well let me just say that this
isn't any Old Colony as well as we are
finally back with the gambling madman
himself Hikari Kenji and the multitude
of his battles throughout Tokyo Colony
number two but just before we do go any
further if you guys are new around here
and want to watch more stuff just like
this then make sure you hit that
subscribe button and also be sure to
leave a like on the video as it really
helps out with pushing my content into a
bunch of new amazing people but anyway
enough of that let's get into the
absolute Beatdown that is Jujutsu
kaizen's Cullen game so to start things
off here we're actually throwing away
any idea of that silly old culling game
and going back to before the Countrywide
Idol Transfiguration where a young man
with blue hair and blue eyes named
Charles Bernard filled out as visitors
registration at shuacia's Publishing
House in Tokyo two of these staff
members noticed and discussed if he
brought him manga submission in also
commenting on how unusual it is for a
guy gym to do so ciao lady ends up
meeting a show Asia staff member to
review his manga submission while I'm
probably sitting on the desk Charles
expresses that he's always pondered what
makes a manga Creator they don't need
licenses and in child's opinion
experience doesn't necessarily validate
a creation either which you know does
make sense like he see armor for example
never hitting manga before Attack on
Titan but anyways anyways the employee
looked over at Bernard's manga while
hardly listening to his words wishing
that he would just sit in the chair he
only commented on the foreigners
Japanese saying that it was pretty good
but Charles responded by repeating the
same sentiment bag confusing a man hate
to cut myself off again but if you guys
watch anyone who like makes Japanese
content and lives in Japan as a
foreigner this is a pretty common thing
to hear to the point that it's like
almost an unhand insult by the Japanese
people to like Outsiders living in Japan
anyway anyway the employee stated that
it's obviously the case because he's
Japanese and Charles reveals that he was
actually born and raised in Japan
although his parents are Fringe the
employee apologized for assuming and
Charles dismissed it because he believed
it would be the start of a long
relationship between him and the
publishing Studio yo yet this dog of
shueisha employee is mostly unimpressed
by Charles's manga submission and
critiques the story The genre the tone
and most of all the artwork he is one
example of one panel where a character's
finger is bent too much in One Direction
the employee tries to show Charles by
pointing his own finger in demonstration
but Charles immediately breaks it to
match the Marcus our hearts irritated
Charles told the man to watch movies or
stare at photos if he wanted realistic
artwork he believed a publishing house
should appreciate the passion that can't
be replicated in precise artwork Charles
finishes his tirade after assaulting the
employee and storms out of the building
deeming the experience is a waste of
time so yeah I don't know what that was
all about probably just a small warning
from gig8 to any future Publishers about
his artwork skipping forward now to the
fateful day of November 12th we find
that somehow this pure manga reading
degenerate Charles is outside and on a
ferris wheel with akari Kenji inside of
the culling game he asks Takara if he
knows what makes someone a manga Creator
yet as we could probably imagine an
annoyed Hikari answers that he simply
doesn't care
just lacking there and chilling out
Charles is thankful that there is still
electricity power in the area but akari
isn't and suggests that he normally
wouldn't ride a ferris wheel with
another man Charles points out that he
could have refused the ride but akari
wants to scope out the area in case he
brings a girl back one day because you
know big brain thinking and all
pre-planning for future events as the
man knows that the killing game ain't
gonna murder him for sure but anyway
Charles is surprised to carry believes
Tokyo will recover from the culling game
claiming that he is the exact opposite
as someone who's only come to gaze upon
the end of a tall ever since curses
flooded Tokyo they haven't been outlets
for manga and creators that Charles
respected are giving up Charles asks
Sakari to giving me reason to fight
because the heroes and battle mangas are
always fighting for positive reasons
while the culling game only incites
fights for negative ones Charles asks
zakara to provoke him enough to instill
hatred inside of him to the point where
he could take him out without any
remorse hearing this Hikari decides to
oblige and thoroughly insults child he
says that it would never reach Charles's
creepy manga because his gloomy
disposition might affect him then and
probably one of the best and tired damn
lines so far of the manga he also tells
Charles to stop whining and start
fighting creepy otaku insulted and with
tears in his eyes Charles asks why he
would say such a mean thing ready to
fight akari for his rude comments
Charles conjures the g-war stuff a
pin-shaped sphere immediately he
attacked bursting through the Pod and
forcing the curry onto the ferris wheel
where his assault continues Charles
thrusts his spirit akari's head several
times while quoting a poem from a
Creator he admires Hikari simply a voice
he strikes and jumps off the Furious
wheel onto a building below cause in the
Frenchman to chase after standing there
it is showing that our special grade is
a little annoyed because Charles is
actually quoting a comment from katsura
hoshino which akari just doesn't
consider as a poem Charles expands upon
the poem by explaining that a mangaka
enters a fictitious space in their minds
where anything is possible because to
them reality just isn't satisfying he
continues by stating he believes his
reality has been overtaken by Jujutsu
and because of this he has lost his
motivation as both a manga reader and a
Creator he asks Sakari what that feeling
is called and the suspended student just
simply replies that he's just getting
bored with this as his fighting Spirit
then begins Rising Charles suggests that
they fill in his God is called a spear
and steered fueled by his sorrow for his
opponent Charles strikes hard with his
g-war staff and scratches akari's cheek
open drawing a bit of blood at the pin's
tub noticing that the spear is a pin
akari asks him if it's okay for a
mangaka to use their drawing pin for
violence but Charles argues using a
reference from Captain Tsubasa following
this he activates the condition for his
curse technique and marks akari with a
glowing Square curiously confused Curry
asks what's going on as he throws a
flying kick but Charles is able to avoid
it and immediately counter attacks with
an attack surprising the former easily
though Hikari maintains his balance as
he's knocked back several meters from
the blow although he personally didn't
take any damage his sleeve was cut wide
open while examining the tear Hikari
also analyzed the way the Frenchman
moved and decides that it has to be more
than just a simple reflex noticing this
special grade sorcerer took his hands
out of his pockets for the first time
Charles taunts him for it and then
explains that the glowing square is
actually a manga panel that lets the
user see their opponent's next move
currently the Frenchman can only see one
second in advance but is the pins tip
fills with Curry's blood the former will
be able to see further into the future
having heard this Hikari Dash is
straight at Charles to confirm this
ability as effect and nearly lands a
powerful right Hawk with the letter
admitting that it would have taken him
out if not for the effect of the g-war
staff quickly after Charles counters
with his attack and had to carry across
the head with the blunt end of his spear
affirming to Hikari then the Frenchman
can really see the future however Hikari
is unimpressed by this dude's ability
and just disappears from Charles's line
of sight before he reappears and punches
Charles in the back stating that he
needs to be able to see him in order to
see the future through his technique to
counter Hikari attacks Charles
repeatedly from his blind spots without
losing R in an attempt to retaliate
Charles tries to stamp a curry in the
bag but the letter has already
anticipated that he would try that and
intercepts before striking him again
before Charles can turn around and
recover carry completely and utterly
blocked his son was stating that he
can't just go easy on him because he
knows Charles would just selfishly
attack someone else later continuing
Hikari believes that in order to stop
this he needs to utterly break Charles
and hits him with an extremely powerful
punch he then quickly goes to get behind
him but Charles is able to recover from
the previous punch in time and
reactively Strikes his blind spot
cutting the Curry's forehead I rate over
how the battle is going now Charles
claims that the official container in
his heart is broken and is spilling out
and a gush of emotion hears it now due
to gaining more ink in his pin he can
see two seconds into hikari's future and
will be waiting in his own blind spot
confused as to why Hikari isn't
intimidated though Charles asks his
opponent why he's just standing there
posing while in the situation don't
actually think Charles has ever bumped
into anyone who can use the domain
expansion and due to this while Hikari
stands there he uses both his hands to
form the proper hand sign to cast his
domain expansion the idol death gamble
due to his domains guaranteed effect its
rules are instantly transmitted to
Charles's brain instantly be soon to be
mangako begins to understand the rules
of akari's domain expansion it's shown
to us that the idol death gamble is
based on the Japanese Pachinko machine
inspired by the Shoujo series sea odd
private Pure Love Train during the
domain's active phase the user must hit
the jackpot by getting three of the same
symbol which will allow them to get a
bonus there's a flow of three different
levels of determines the percentage of
increased probability and also the
probability of the jackpot through a
visual effect which akari can choose
though ultimately this depends on the
so-called luck Hikari refers to also
certain Richie scenarios can be
activated at points throughout this
process and chance boosters allow for an
increase in the chance of a jackpot
having heard all of this child yells at
annoyed by the sudden info dump that was
literally just implanted into his brain
as the first stage of akari's domain
begins quickly Kenji releases a green
and red vigil effect attack which
Charles Dodges out of the way causing it
to activate into a raichi scenario
changing the scene around them it's
explained to the confused Charles that
if the character Yuki passes through the
gate then Hikari immediately hits the
jackpot chaos attempts to swipe at it
but it's just a visualization so nothing
happens meaning all he can do is wait to
see the result which is you know like
kind of sucks it's almost just a
guaranteed jackpot whenever a HD
scenario pops up I wonder if like that's
a house rule type thing referring back
to how his domain is based on pachinka
machine but anyway anyway we're going to
take back over due to the indicator
being weak the Richie scenario fails
causing them to reset back at the
beginning of the domain's expansion
these sequence of events leading up to
either the reset of the domain or a
jackpot are considered one of akari's
full roles giving Charles a very strict
time limit to defeat the gambling
sorcerer standing there Charles thinks
about how he can't use his manga curse
technique to predict the outcome meaning
that the process will repeat
continuously until he defeats him or
Kenji draws a winner which he knows will
result in a loss for him however
takenji's surprise watch House's most
infuriated ad is the presentation taking
the Beloved private pure love trained
manga and turning it into something
bizarre for gambling he continues to try
and attack questioning how long he will
keep up with the jackpot rate being only
one in 239 however Hikari is still able
to easily Dodge each attack while
confidently stating that he's never gone
past 30 times this time Hikari activates
a Rachel scenario with an 80 success
rate leaving them too anxiously watching
as they continue to Juke it out he's
unable to focus on kenji's future
attacks as he tries to pay attention to
the Reiki scenario calling on the Yume
character to get on the train in hopes
of preventing the jackpot sadly for him
though the train leaves and Yume
disappears allowing Charles to slice a
takari's side Charles explains while
confidently stand in there that if it
was a game of skill rather than luck
Hikari might have won but as he turns
around he is utterly shocked to find
Hume is still standing there saying that
she missed the train meaning that Hikari
had actually indeed won the jackpot
quickly Hikari darts in and kicks
Charles away declaring that he uses
skill to grab a hold of luck elsewhere
in Tokyo number two Colony Panda sits
alone atop a shipping container in a
shipyard upon smelling the air he notes
that roughly three people have been
dismembered nearby he can also hardly
sense the perpetrator's presence which
might suggest that they can freely
activate their curse energy Panda
reviews the plan that he and everyone
had agreed on beforehand they'd planned
to leave the fighting just to Hikari but
the barrier just like over in Tokyo
Colony 1 with Yuji and Megami split them
up upon entry to one of those random
spawn locations after a bit more
thinking Panda decides to take off and
rolls his cute behind off the shipping
container to go in search of Hana once
he landed he looks both ways and size a
breath of relief however at that exact
moment Hajime kashimo walks right around
the corner in a split-second reaction
Panda plays a real-life Panda and
initially this does work however Hajime
has an omega-sized brain and summons has
go getting to a side to ask if that
Panda was actually a player with the
letter pretty much instantly confirming
nerds with to seeing this happen in
front of his teddy bear eyes Panda was
surprised to learn that they have that
function yes before Panda really had any
time to react the ancient god-level
sorcerer Hajime had quickly charged at
him and delivered a powerful blow to his
torso completely erupting a large
portion of his stuffing holding him
together before following up this brutal
attack and completely electrifying him
then not done Hajime while insulting his
strength hits him with his stuff and
knocks Panda back into a container
having been brutally beaten Panda notes
that hajime's cursed energy is similar
to megami's new way where both have
electrified cursed energy surging
through their bodies with his Panda form
destroyed the Puppeteer begins
transforming into his gorilla mode and
Strikes Hajime with the prolific
unblockable drumming beat noticing a
change Hajime takes his offensive starts
and endures the multitude of blows he
says that the attack wasn't too bad but
it wasn't great either and follows up by
using a start tear off the Panda's right
arm then continuing with his old school
brutality he throws panda his own arm
straight back into his face completely
blinding the defenseless beer allowing
the sneaky sorcerer to approach him for
the puppet's right dating he delivers a
flurry of absolutely brutal hurts
directly aimed at the Panda's face
sending him shooting back into another
container as the broken sorcerer strolls
up on the Beast and Panda he calls him
pathetic and weak before asking if he
knows the current whereabouts of sukuna
taken by surprise Panda doesn't know why
he's interested in him but quickly comes
to the realization that he wouldn't be a
good matchup with Yuji so while trying
to think up an excuse he says he doesn't
know noticing the massive amount of
stalling before answering his question
though Hajime realizes that he's indeed
lying and demands that he spit it out as
he'll show Mercy if he does having
thought up an excuse now Panda says that
his uncle goes by the same name so
hearing it took him off guard initially
Hajime who easily figures out that he's
still lying doesn't appreciate being
looked down on by the cursed puppet and
tells him to stop playing with him
annoyed now panda torch by saying he's
the one being looked down on and tells
him to be aware of his sister as anyone
who meets her eyes she tries to kill at
a pure embarrassment all of a sudden a
massive horn is seen from Panda's nose
as his body begins to transform and his
head Morse into a giant Triceratops
skull however in that exact moment
Hajime charges up his own attack and a
lightning bolt appears between them as
soon explained that kashimo separates
the curse Energy's charges like
electricity when he strikes an opponent
so like all of the hits of these lines
on Panda earlier it transfers a positive
charge into the target then when the
negative charge that lays inside of
kashimo is discharged and launches
directly at the Target without shooting
off any other surface this results in
lightning that like literally cannot
mess as it will travel directly to its
opponent pretty much taking away any
need for Kashima to actually use the
domain as this is kinda a short head
technique in itself sadly for panda as
the transformation is still happening
that said lightning bolt strikes and
absolutely decimates Panda mortally
wounding him stay and above the now
fallen puppet Hajime once again asks
Panda about sakuna's whereabouts ah boys
here here's the saddest part here's the
saddest Panda chipper so far as we flow
into a flashback we see a young Panda
being beaten up by his big brother
gorilla the young Teddy screams for a
sister's aide and an angry Triceratops
marches over demanding that gorilla sees
the bullying yet the young gorilla tries
to say that they were just fighting like
a dude from a game here and there
Triceratops says that Panda should get
the next turn to fight back with gorilla
being completely fine with it listening
to his older siblings Panda looking like
hella cute man rolls up to smack his bra
a few times however he quickly is
punched in the face by the letter making
him cry even more completely blown away
with what she just witnessed Triceratops
then runs off in Pursuit while Panda
continues crying out behind them later
on panda is seen holding a Santa Claus
ball while trying to follow his older
brother and his puppet friends not
wanting him to follow because they find
they like training wheels absolutely
lame the fox Whispers something in the
raccoon's air and he tells Panda that he
can actually join under the conditions
that he throws his ball into the river
initially Panda hesitates claiming that
it was a gift from Santa but after the
two pressured him and seen his older
brother's grumpy steer Panda tosses the
ball into the river Blown Away with him
actually doing it the raccoon and the
fox tell him that throwing stuff into
the river is illegal as it would harm
the environment before they ran off
aiming to tell the police which is like
who is Gorilla hanging out with these
are the worst puppets I've ever met
gorilla really asks a sad and Panda way
through his ball into the river telling
him that it was a precious gift from
Santa breaking down in tears even more
Panda screams at him that he just wanted
to play with his big brother at night
before bedtime Triceratops berates
gorilla for bullying Panda instead
telling him that when other kids peck on
him he has to be the one to stand up for
him gorilla counters this by stating
that she plays with the other girls and
wouldn't understand because of this he
says that he can never have fun with
panda around as he holds him back and
only ever seems to start crying when she
shows up up gorilla thinks that she's
far too caution him but Triceratops
views this differently she knows that no
matter how main gorilla is to him Panda
strikes off all the bad things and
cheers up by the time it's time to Aid
he literally doesn't have a bad bone in
his body and believes that that's how
Brothers should always be she belittles
Gorilla by saying then maybe he's the
spoiled one as Panda always ends up
forgiving him for his transgressions
suddenly interrupting the two of him
pendethine storms into the room with a
beetle and shows it to gorilla who
immediately points out that it's
actually a dorkus Titania stag beetle
and screams while throwing it out of the
window in horror before going to beard
gorilla and his sister opened the piggy
bank to see if they have enough change
to buy a replacement ball for panda as
he then begins trying to sleep he just
thinks that an idiot like Panda would be
fine with any ball suddenly though in
the middle of the night a voice tells
him to wake up coming out of the days he
notices that both he and Triceratops are
being led by a strange ghost man who's
obviously like some puppet version of
masamichi for real but anyway he quickly
this figure is their father and asks
where they're going and for how long to
which their father answers that there's
no reason and that it's permanent at
that moment a terrified Panda bursts out
of the house desperately searching for
his big bro and big cerseus gorilla
screams back for panda and tells his
father to stop however the ghostly man
just tells him that that's enough
gorilla Cuts in by saying that Panda
can't survive without him since he's
literally terrible at everything he does
and we get left behind because he's
completely helpless by himself not
understanding what's actually going on
though the father tells him that they're
the ones being left behind and not Panda
so be a good big brother and Say Goodbye
a confused gorilla gets defensive
wondering but how in the world he was
going to buy a ball for him tomorrow and
that he needed him there to talk to
these shopkeepers instead of their
sister but sadly after a second thought
he finally catches on and fully begins
to break down in tears not wanting to
leave this world and his little
brother's side back in the real world
now Hajime kashimo stands over the
bloodied mess of pandas obliterated
corpse while prodding the beer he knows
that he didn't gain any points from him
before realizing that he probably hasn't
found the core of the panda years he
picks up Panda's head with his staff and
asks once again about the whereabouts of
sukuna but Panda simply replies like the
true friend and Legend he is that pandas
are very tight-lipped taking this as an
insult Hajime threatens to fully destroy
the rest of panda yet just as he raises
blood loss to do so the legend himself
but this cursed energy already fully
flared up and with the anger of the
entire Jujutsu tick on his back drops in
completely destroying a shipping
container in the process instantly he
screams at his boy asking if Panda has
lost some weight seeing his classmate
arrive panda is happy and shouts at
akari's name while an initially confused
Hajime begins to get riled up
supercharged with an incredible volume
of cursed energy akari rushes in to
rescue Panda from kashimo he delivers a
right Hawk so powerful that it disarms
kashimo and since the sorcerer crashing
through several fake containers oh like
this battle was going to be so insane
boys and and girls of course anyways
anyways instantly Hikari follows up not
giving kashimo any time to recover
having closed the distance the special
grade does a sick two-footed jump
throwing himself into the air and
delivering a flying drop kick to his
opponent's face the hejima just narrowly
avoids while still a media though akari
swings his leg straight back in an
attempt to land ahead with his opponent
just barely having his nose grazed
essajime stands there in shock hikari's
physical power is so overwhelming that
his kicks excess cursed energy dense
another shipping container and
completely deforms it sending opposite
her Gmail Hikari is electrified by the
curse energy protecting his opponent but
also barely feels the bad side effects
from it Kashima was impressed that his
opponent can ignore the electrification
and asks his name Hikari introduces
himself while kashimo is just completely
fascinated by the insane curse energy
output and mysterious music surrounding
his opponent moving into his fighting
stance kishimo also introduces himself
and asakari hears his name he realizes
that he he is the player with 100 points
knowing that he needs them he cheekily
asks if he can use those points of his
Victorious with kashimo green and asking
to know more about sakona if he's the
Victor feeling that coming in Hikari is
suddenly and orgasmically distracted as
a large influx of curse energy received
as a bonus from heading his domain's
jackpot envelops him noticing that
something's up kishimo uses the
opportunity to barrage his opponent with
several hits but quickly becomes
displeased as akari isn't resisting at
all as he begins to tell Hikari to not
disappoint him the special grade
sorcerer switches things up a little and
rattles the ancient sorcerer with an
Abrupt right hop to the jaw that since
kashimo absolutely flying after posing
literally playing the ear guitar to go
along with his own damn theme song
Hikari instantaneously disappears from
his body was in to follow up with a fly
need to hajime's gut prompting him to
admit that his opponent isn't bad at all
Landing back on his fate Hajime regained
his balance grabs onto the lake
occurring Nathan with encounter attacks
with a spinning elbow straight to the
chin of the sorcerer overcoming at the
though Hikari will stands the attack and
forces kashimo to release his grip by
jumping down and completely smashing the
ground beneath their feet with a
straight punch jumping back out of a
Curry's range Kashima who's charged back
up discharges the same lightning attack
the defeated Panda being able to see the
approaching lightning Hikari is able to
avoid the Direct Hit to his head but
sadly his arms blown off by the attack
glad and confident that his opponent
won't be able to recover in time after
being hurt kashimo rushes in to finish
him off however the carriers on his gone
level of strength and literally does not
care about his arm at all instead he
surprisingly counters where they kick
straight to hajime's face and follows up
with a punch from the same arm that was
supposedly just severed blown away by
seeing hikari's arm reappear hashimo
just manages to block the attack and
assumes akari used the reverse curse
technique to quickly heal himself it's
then explained that when hakara hit the
jackpot with his domain expansion it
resulted in a bonus of unlimited curse
energy throughout the round Hikari
himself never actually learned to use
reverse curse technique but the
unlimited curse energy coursing
throughout his body as a result of mini
jackpot automatically heals his body
with thirds in other words Curry is
pretty much damn Immortal for 4 minutes
and 11 seconds after hitting the jackpot
this time limit comes to an end as the
ancient sorcerer notices the random
music surrounding Hikari has stopped
causing his opponent's cursed energy to
recede to normal however during the
previous round and due to hawakari's
curse technique Works after he hits a
jackpot his curse energy and technique
is replenished allowing him to cast
another domain immediately so for as
long as akari continues to hit his
jackpot he can use his domain over and
over and over again so this is the main
reason why Hikari is absolutely broken
and Gojo reasons that he could surpass
him someday man literally has figured
out an infinite cursed energy hack like
this is some game of magic or something
like oh my Lord but anyway anyway
because of the fact that big rari's
domain expansion is harmless he can be
as aggressive as he wants and his
activation is extremely quick probably
one of the quickest in the entire
universe like it states here that the
dude's activation is faster than that of
Mojito's John yeah as the roles of the
idol death game are sent to hejima's
mind he knows that since he's aware the
game is a probability loot type and
means he's likely to keep hitting the
jackpot as he activates increased
probability standing there hakari asks
him how he is but Jimmy points out that
during this period he's not actually
unkillable and akari simply responds
that the life of gambling has always
come with great risks flashing in the
two monstrous Sorcerers traded flurry of
brutal punches before Kenji spins away
and activates his continuation effect
absolutely confusing her Gmail with
what's going on as soon explained that
currently Hikari is redoing one
consecutive effect sequence the normal
percentage chance of hitting the jackpot
is over 20 or one in five on his first
activation and because of that there is
usually a high risk of drawing a dud so
typically he only uses this activation
when he has increased probability
igniting the fight once more Hikari
throws another punch but Hajime blocks
it and completely Benders the bulked up
high schooler punching him in the side
of the head and needing him in his
stomach jumping effect though Curry
flexes while screaming renewal leading
the potty emergency reichy scenario to
occur during this Raichu scenario if the
dingy wannabe who stuck on a
hypothetical train headed to yoyogi
doesn't have a bathroom or more
specifically as it implies here doesn't
have any accident at all will result in
a jackpot reichy scenario for Hikari as
the train flies forward it's shown that
this fake chainsaw man named hero just
barely made it to a stop of our accident
causing Hikari to once again hit his
jackpot standing there with his eyes
closed and just looking like the
absolute King he is Hikari suddenly
reopens his eyes and screams for his
music to begin once more sometimes you
know like I I really just personally
wish I could make sound effects like
with my mouth and everything just like
boom as akari finishes speaking his body
once again erupts with a flood of curse
energy restarting his invincibility and
the brutal Showdown some like to really
kick things up a notch here boys so
subscribe to please save my throat from
the throat code and push this video to
like 5 or 10K likes just so I know that
you want a full like four hour jjk video
Drop because you know I'll compile all
these parts together and re-edit the
Gojo past Arc and you know I'll do that
or I'll do that or I'll tell you oh well
don't make me anyway moving forward
standing opposite him and Jimmy notes
how this is the same form that will last
for four minutes and 11 seconds meaning
that he currently has no restrictions on
cursed energy and can automatically
activate a reverse curse technique
however he also notes that this time the
jackpot was not an even number meaning
that if he activates his domain
expansion right after this his increased
probability will have actually ended so
we won't get another jackpot again as
quickly after he states to himself
though that if he can make it through
the next 4 minutes and 11 seconds he
will win but as his smile grows larger
he recognizes that that line of thinking
is how losers think instead he screams
that it's time to turn up the volume
because this is a funeral for the living
He releases a massive burst of cursed
energy to clearing that even though he
may be unkillable for the next 4 minutes
and 11 seconds he will still kill him
anyway oh but before we go any further
we skip back in time to a moment 400
years ago where her Jimmy was approached
by kanjaku asking if he had fun with his
battle honestly any thoughts on who's in
the brain swapping fiend's body right
here I like wouldn't be surprised if it
was Naruto shikemo to be honest but who
knows let me know what you think down
below anyways anyways after replying
that he didn't have fun at all wanting
to fight him instead kinjaku asks him to
spear him and says that he is not fit
for fighting currently but reveals he
heard something in michinoku about the
greatest cursed energy output ever
coughing up blood though Hajime asks
kinjaku who's the strongest source for a
he knows if you later replying that it's
a Kona before apologizing that it was
from 600 years ago and saying that he
would never change his mind on that fact
realizing that he will never get to
fulfill his own wishes Hajime responds
that if that's the case he will
entertain what kinjaku has to say so
that he can fight sakuna himself
back in the battle they fight between
kashimo and Hikari intensifies as they
both Chase each other at high speeds
around the port sajimay starts to get
away akari launches another Fat punch
that connects with a shipping container
sending it straight towards the ancient
sorcerer seeing it coming In Time Hajime
responds with his own brutal punch
filling in the container straight back
at the approaching student with him both
being on opposite sides of the container
they both exchanged a multitude of blows
on each side of the metal box completely
deforming and destroying it however
asakari breaks through ready to throw a
massive punch kishimo Dodges by jumping
off the ground before he manages to blow
half of a Curry's freaking face off with
his shipping container door exposing his
face muscles and jaw with he fights
slowing for a moment Hajime deduces that
cursed energy comes from the guard but
he has to use his head to direct the
flow of reverse curse technique so no
matter how powerful his reverse curse
technique is it certainly can't be
strong enough to regenerate his head
therefore Kashima plans to use his
lightning to Target his head and
complexly split it open following this a
Jimmy senses lightning directly at akari
connecting with his head yet I am here
to tell you that this is just not a
normal human this is Hikari kinji and
man just simply blows out all of the
energy from the attack straight out of
his damn nose as it destroys his face
literally allowing him to regenerate as
he breaks realizing that he almost died
there Hikari being as cool as ever just
lasted off and with only eight seconds
remaining on his jackpot shoots in
deciding to use even more brute force in
his punches now after taking a plethora
of punches to the face chin and body
Hajime darts back realizing that akari
is getting even faster as the Fight
Continues getting straight back to his
face though and with only a few seconds
remaining akari who's completely
unkillable decides to cut loose and
totally beat down on his opponent
elbowing him hard in his guards yet
surprisingly this turns out to be
exactly what kashimot actually wanted
and as he smiles he retrieves a massive
streak of electrical feedback using his
staff piston to the ground at some
distance the streak of instantaneous
lightning passes through the left side
of the Curry's tour also on its way to
Hajime before completely and utterly
blowing into pieces mortally wounding
the student just then the theme song
ends Mark in the end of akari's
unkillable period with Hajime then
stating that it's finally over however
to the public surprise of the ancient
sorcerer Hikari is not done yet instead
moving his hands into placement and
opening his domain once more sadly it's
showing though that Hikari is just
making a desperate attempt at casting
his domain after activating his domain
Hikari keeps trying to spin faster even
if the probability is only one in 239
immediately Hajime catches on though as
the rules are implanted in his brain and
once again Hikari somehow let the dude
is a completely not a demon gains an
unexpected jackpot due to some kind of
increased probability allowing him to
roll an even number therefore he is
again unkillable for the next 4 minutes
and 11 seconds breathing a sigh of
relief Hikari states that his impressed
with kashimo as he's never faced death
this much in one day but now thanks to
some manga otaku he's got a big manga
brain and asks her Gmail if he also
likes manga with the letter stating that
he doesn't get any battle underway akari
flips things up a notch figuratively and
literally as he changes his domains
polarities making down up and also
Shifting the coordinates of his barrier
Over the Sea as a Gmail falls back
towards the sea below him he states that
because his cursed energy is like
electricity it won't stop discharging
until it's fully deplete heard here's
one of two options in the coming water
tussle either he can release his cursed
energy until it's all gone or shattered
off until he's able to return to land
this obviously goes back to like what
Panda said about someone having that
amazing control over their curse energy
at the beginning of this battle but
anyway anyway however to avoid falling
into the water kishimo stands on the
curse spirits that burst out of the
ocean in an attempt to devour him on the
other hand Hikari who's got his manga
brain fully rolling absolutely pummels a
massive curse Spirit as it bursts out of
the ocean before shooting across at high
speeds toward tajime and see in him
flying into the ocean below with a fat
Kirk then floating above him on some
like fat flying fish look and ask her
spirit he watches it's a Gmail slowly
begins to burn away all of his cursed
energy and the water however Kashima is
actually smarter than this he recalls
that there are two ways to any reverse
cursed energy user one by simply blowing
up their brains or two by using toxins
therefore he uses his electricity on the
sea water to produce a chlorine gas that
completely takes akari by surprise as he
floats above sadly Hikari loses his grip
on the curse monster and ends up falling
into the sea due to the Toxic effect of
chlorine gas it's explained that unlike
simple body regeneration addressing a
toxin and one's blood requires insane
skill as well as a higher level of
reverse curse techniques sinking down
through the ocean Jimmy notes that
Hikari doesn't seem to be able to
detoxify fast enough causing the round
to end and allowing hikari's immortality
Shield to fade smgma States this has
been fun preparing to finish him off
akari just like before dispels the
excess cursed energy right out of his
freaking nose and throws a vicious punch
straight into the face of a Gmail taking
him completely by surprise were they too
floating back from each other after the
attack it turns out that the legend of
Jujutsu Tech targeted the toxins in his
body and removed him unconsciously by
his automatic reverse curse energy with
only five seconds left in his jackpot
Hikari realizes casting his domain again
after this one ends will be dangerous
due to the effects of electricity
coursing through the water and the
steadily increasing temperature of the
ocean he Ponders going up to the surface
but it's like nah stuff that dude I
might instead just beat the absolute
hell out of the stood here and proceeds
to throw fairly talk to his opponent's
face kishime though battered and bruised
but still excited to continue drives
forth and grabs a hold of akari's arm
before releasing a massive blast of
electrified cursed energy in an attempt
to destroy hikari's entire arm and
prevent him from being able to cast his
domain again back above the ocean's
surface as all the water rains down we
find a cute baby panda who's changed his
form wandering around as he then comes
cross a car receiving hand as a
previously Lively battle now comes to a
seemingly abrupt end we'll see kashimo
pop out of this sea completely out of
curse energy however right as he is
about to consider himself the winner
Hikari emerges from the sea himself with
one arm and punches him back to reality
it's explained that during the previous
attack a Gmail released before the
electricity could travel all the way
through the water and resulted in a
massive thermal explosion of hot steam
laying down on the ground completely
exhausted Hajime asks how he isn't
ripped apart from this explosion but
akari explains that he knew what his
opponent was up to and purposely
sacrificed his left arm through a
binding vowel so that the curse energy
that usually protected her protected the
wrist of his body hearing this kishimo
finally tells his enemy to end his life
however akari offers him a deal instead
as he personally doesn't see this as a
win akari also brings up how kashimo
technically didn't use his technique to
which the Ancient One actually explains
that he is saving his cursed technique
to use on sakona as it is a single-use
one and okushima wants as a fight for
sakona therefore the ancient sorcerer
agrees to side with akari in exchange
for a future duel with the king of
curses rolling onto the scene and seeing
the two hanging out panda is quite
shocked after hearing that Hajime is now
on the side because he wants to have a
future belt with sakuna Hikari discards
Panda's concerns by casually asserting
that a kohai has to obey his senpai's
wish before randomly leaving the small
panda with the ancient sorcerer to go in
search of someone else this is also
where the announcement of a new rule
being added to the game is made the rule
is that players can also give as many
points as they want to another player
allowing Hajime to send his points over
when like needed obviously it's actually
crazy when you think about it how like
all of these battles are happening
simultaneously like I love how Giga
hasn't given us a timeline per se to go
off but it's more or less just this one
kind of rule that we can refer back to
knowing that all of the fights have been
like in relation with her but anyway
anyway continuing shooting back over to
the Furious wheel we find that Charles
has been chilling out after his defeat
after seeing Hikari rolling up he
confusingly asks what happened to his
his arm with the students stating that
he'll fix it later the two mates then
Becca about their fight hilariously like
akari is actually abusing the dude an
attempt to get the name of his monk out
of him because he'll Buy and read it
what she you know is very nice of him
big plot Twisted I'm gonna Chuck in here
myself that man uh no operator were
talking about for a sick what if Giga is
actually um French himself and this is
like a self-insert of him in the actual
story it'd be kind of funny to like go
back to after the story if Kiki ever
reveals himself and find out that this
was just like himself inserting you know
I'd love to know what you guys think on
that down in the comment section below
but anyway anyway continuing on big Momo
then cruises on and interrupting their
banter and asking if he managed to get
all their points necessary with akari
confirming that he indeed did so uh
quickly before the uh video ends I guess
I better go over their plan So the plan
is obviously to implement four new rules
the first was to make points
transferable to new players which was
done the second is to allow the use of a
hundred points to create a substitute
player so individuals can actually leave
the game third is to remove
communication blocks on these zones and
then finally the fourth is to allow
people in and out of all the barriers
without Consequence the shimaya states
that she wants to forget rule three for
now in place of going to get four first
the reason they like are doing this
obviously is because Marquee can
actually pass through barriers leaving a
carry shocked at this news that she can
thrill you into them he asks how it's
possible with Momo stating that it's
because she has turned into a complete
monster
so that brings us to the very end of the
video for today's insane Arc from Geiger
katame institutes to Kaizen what do you
guys think on like or who do you guys
think is going to win when Yuji or
sakuna finally does get to go up against
Hajime and probably the upcoming future
because I'd imagine we're not going to
get tased on that fire and then not get
it Hajime ain't gonna live for 600 years
and then not get their fight like
there's just no way of course shout out
to big broken Ronin and no operator for
hopping on this video as this was my
first collab with someone on the channel
so I'd love to know if you guys like
want more stuff just like that down in
the comment section below where I get
another YouTuber to come in and play
like specific roles in the video plus
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button if you guys are new around here
as well and leave a like on the video as
it really does help out with pushing my
content to a bunch of new amazing people
of course check out my patreon as well
if you want to support me even further
but anyways for now it's being
professional degenerate diavolo and I
will see you all enable bye